Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Conner said I'm going to do a short little video to remind people how to
Order their 23 and me
get order to
Get the genetics rolling. We were waiting for our new genetic kit. We were still waiting
And I have just grown very tired of that, but we did receive notice
That the software has been upgraded. So we're going to be able to better read the 600,000 steps
That we're going to get with the 23 and me now. We're going to get 900,000 with our new genetics kit
Which is one third more, but still 600,000 steps is one heck of a lot of steps. It'll care how you slice the pie
That's a lot of steps so we can be able to look at a lot of your genetics through this. So those that are anxious
And wanted another picture of how their health is going. I suggest that you order the 23 and me
So you have to go to 23 and me.com in order to order it or you can go to target
Or you can go to a CVS or you can go to Walmart or you can even go to Best Buy
Yes, how does Best Buy correlate with genetics and health. I have no idea, but they sell them there
We can't as practitioners
Purchase them and sell them as kids to our patients anymore, but you can buy them at Best Buy. I don't know
Or you can order at 23 and me either way when you purchase the kit
I think you pay like $29 for the kit at any of those places
Then you go online to 23andme.com or you can simply go online to 23andme.com in order the kit
But by going to the store you're saving yourself a couple days. It's all you're doing
And then if you paid $29 for it at Best Buy or Target
You would only pay the difference of the 99 or the one 99 depending on which service that you pick
So the 23andme.com is going to give you two different choices the ancestry only service or the health and ancestry service
This is the one that we want this both of them give you the same amount of gene steps that they read
This one just gives you a whole bunch of nice little nice nice reports that you might find helpful
I don't want to look at them. So I have nothing to do with those. That's your choice
This is the one that we really want is the $99 one
That's what gives us if that was what will tell you what your ancestry is yes
That's why they call it ancestry service remember 23 me is trying to compete with the ancestry.com
That's why they've kind of changed their names of different things here too
So um, but this will give us the 600,000 plus steps that we need to put in our software in order to
Tell you different things about your health
It's $99 if you order an online again if you bought the kid a target or something you paid the difference between those two
So you have to register your kit. So the whole idea when you get the kit is just to follow the instructions
So it gives you they have really good instructions in their kit. So just follow the instructions
You must register the kit you'll have to create a username and password on 23andme.com
Write that down save it because we need it. So you need to email us your 23andme.com
User name and password. Please do not call and tell us it over the phone
Email it to us so I could copy it and paste it in there and get that get your raw data when it comes in
So email us your user name and password that you will have created through 23andme.com
When you register your kit
Now understand when you get your kit you will be told that you have to go on their website and register it
So that they will ask you do you want this one or this one and you make the choice
Um, so this is the one that's in your included in your play alone
They will they will walk you through the steps that you need
It's not a blood test. It's so you don't need to worry about that
It's a saliva test. So you'll be spinning into this tube thing here
Then you just follow the instructions
But when you do register your kit save your username and password and email that to us
And then they'll give you exact
Directions on what to do. So it's really really quite simple. The only time it's people find it difficult to do is
When they have a hard time getting enough spit
So make sure that um you work up some spit and
Bring back the old days when you're on the bone
pitching for your high school teeth. So
Follow the directions get that said did
Uh, just drop it back in the mail. It comes with the prepackage prevailing label on it
And so that we could get that cooking and then we'll
When you send us your username and password and when we
They will not inform us that week that your test is done
They will inform you. Yeah, your test is done. We got it. They'll actually send you an email saying hey
We received your kit. It'll be ex-emoto days or weeks
Uh before we get it back and then they'll send you another email. So watch for their emails
They're pretty good with that and then they'll finally send you an email. Hey your data is ready
And you can look at your ancestry
That's what you want to call our office and make an appointment for a zoom meeting
So we'll do a zoom meeting the individual zoom meeting with you either myself or Dr. Halterman
And we will go over your data
But we will need your username and password to pull the data off of 23me.com to put it into our software so that we can
Spit out a beautiful report for you. So we need that information
So pretty simple just follow the directions. You can get your kit. You can save a little bit of time by getting your kit at Walmart
Or target or best buy or CVS pharmacies and then you'll just go online and follow the instructions exactly that came in the kit
All right, thanks pretty easy and looking forward to get this started not everybody needs to hurry up and do this one
You can still wait and get the larger kit that's gonna have
Uh, you know, a third more snips in it
But uh, uh, we just can't promise. I'm just I know everybody's growing impatient
Nobodies more impatient than Dr. Halterman and I it's just very frustrating
But we don't have any say in it. So um, but we'll get a good reading of these so I'm very excited about the upgraded software
All right, thanks so much. Bye-bye